[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
boleto de vuelta en esta ocasión vamos a
Yuba en Sudán del sur con un momento de
esperanza y optimismo de aquellos que no
se ven muy a menudo en la actualidad
internacional la esperanza del retorno
de la paz y del verdadero nacimiento de
una nación en 2018 el presidente de
Sudán del sur salvair y su eterno rival
react firmaron un acuerdo de paz en el
vecino Sudán había Esperanza sin duda
Pero también bastante pesimismo por
parte de los habitantes de la nación más
joven del mundo independiente solo desde
2011 marcada por una terrible Guerra
Civil desde 2013 y un primer acuerdo de
paz que había caído en el olvido dos
años atrás en 2018 salvakier prometía
que todo había quedado en el pasado y
que esta vez sí habría una paz duradera
hoy cinco años después los habitantes de
la capital Yuba siguen teniendo que
vuelva la
35.000 personas viven en campamentos de
desplazados pero Yuba es una de las
únicas zonas del país donde en general
el acuerdo de paz es respetado el pasado
mes de febrero el Papa Francisco visitó
el país para llevar un mensaje de
Reconciliación sin embargo el conflicto
en el vecino Sudán la inseguridad
alimentaria y las inundaciones que
empeoran como consecuencia del cambio
climático debilitan las esperanzas de
que haya un verdadero desarrollo
económico en uno de los países más
pobres del mundo Esta es la historia
durante un fin de semana el tiempo se
detuvo en Yuba decenas de miles de
personas llegaron de todo el país para
escuchar el mensaje de paz y
Reconciliación del papa
en sus 12 años de existencia el país más
joven del mundo solo ha conocido la
guerra civil el hambre y El Éxodo pero
el pasado mes de febrero El Vaticano
Consideró que la ciudad era lo bastante
segura como para acoger al sumo
pontífice sin embargo muchos siguen
sufriendo las consecuencias del
conflicto 4 millones 500.000
ciudadanenses se encuentran refugiados
en el extranjero o son desplazados
dentro de su propio país es decir un
tercio de la población
[Música]
uno no puede ir a trabajar para ganar un
poco de dinero para su familia
alguien puede seguirlo aún hasta su
granja y matarlo aunque uno sea inocente
cualidad desde 2013 y el inicio de los
combates las masacres étnicas cometidas
por militares y grupos rebeldes
complicado dejando un saldo de al menos
100.000 muertos los acuerdos de paz
firmados en 2018 e implementados
parcialmente desde 2002 le han llevado
cierta estabilidad a la capital sin
embargo más de 35,000 desplazados aún no
se atreven a salir de los campamentos de
lluvia totalmente abandonados por el
gobierno ellos fueron una de las
principales razones de la visita del
Papa 2000 de ellos fueron a conocerlo
ustedes son las semillas de un nuevo
Sudán del sur las semillas que
permitirán que este país crezca
ustedes de todos estos grupos étnicos
diferentes han sufrido y siguen
sufriendo ustedes que no quieren
responder al mal con el mal
María haría cualquier cosa para ponerle
fin a la violencia y hacer que reine la
paz
desplazada interna en su propia ciudad
vive en un campamento de la ONU desde
desde el comienzo de la guerra hasta hoy
la gente ha sufrido mucho
la crisis alimentaria la pobreza los
asesinatos que le no puedo decir que
haya algo que esté bien
algo tiene que pasar
los desplazados que viven en este
campamento llevan 10 años esperando en
vano
la última vez que María recibió ayuda
alimentaria fue hace seis meses
[Música]
cuando vio que una ong distribuía un
poco de dinero probó suerte
[Música]
esta vez no recibió ayuda las donaciones
están reservadas para las personas más
vulnerables
tenemos que ser pacientes con este
dinero podremos comprar la comida que
tanto hemos estado esperando
volveré a venir a esperar mi turno
está en una situación vulnerable pero no
lo suficiente como para recibir ayuda
debilitada por años de violencia María
ya no puede trabajar esta ex enfermera
sobrevive gracias a su familia y amigos
que realizan varios trabajos informales
Este es el tipo de trabajo que hacen las
mujeres
ellas venden huevos y otras cosas así se
las arreglan
Es difícil salir de su refugio y
encontrar un trabajo formal cuando se
firmaron los acuerdos de paz en 2018 que
formalizaban el regreso al país del
líder de la oposición ried muchos
imaginaron marcharse de este lugar pero
nada ha cambiado desde entonces a pesar
de las promesas de los políticos María
sigue viviendo en el campamento por
miedo a más violencia
al principio cuando intentaron que las
cosas avanzaran en la dirección correcta
teníamos esperanzas de que la situación
mejorara
este acuerdo de paz total es muy bueno
pero no entendemos por qué el proceso
está tardando tanto
A veces tenemos mucho miedo de que
ocurra algo malo en realidad no sabemos
que podría pasar
asesinatos violaciones secuestros las
mujeres son las primeras Víctimas de los
horrores de la guerra por eso María
intenta aportar su granito de arena para
que su país salga adelante una vez al
mes reúne a los representantes de los
distintos clanes
deberíamos hablar de temas importantes
como el agua
es un tema importante porque la gente
está peleando por la falta de agua
el objetivo es que juntas encuentren las
mejores palabras para hablar con sus
hijos y maridos y hacer que haya un
cambio de mentalidad
si no organizamos estas reuniones no
podremos hablar de nuestros problemas
por lo que no podríamos ayudar a la
gente Así es como nuestro país mejorará
tengo miedo no quiero volver al 2013
así que tenemos que trabajar juntos
todas estas mujeres son voluntarias ante
la inacción de los políticos decidieron
tomar cartas en el asunto
esperamos provocar un cambio la paz se
construye día a día el día que nuestra
sociedad esté en paz las mujeres
tendremos muchas oportunidades
todos los yubaneses se aferran a esta
esperanza
los últimos enfrentamientos en la
capital se remontan a Julio de 2016
cientos de personas murieron
[Música]
desde entonces todo rastro de los
enfrentamientos ha desaparecido reina
una calma precaria en la ciudad que está
creciendo lentamente
algunas personas están trasladando a las
afueras de la capital
es originario del sur de la región donde
continúa la violencia entre comunidades
cuando los enfrentamientos menguaron se
instaló aquí a orillas del Nilo para
dedicarse a la agricultura
son las tierras de otro no me pertenecen
tengo que alquilarlas mi tierra está en
mi pueblo pero ahora vivo aquí en la
ciudad y tengo que pagar cuando hago
cuentas me doy cuenta de que a veces
gano dinero y otras veces lo pierdo Pero
sigo adelante para sobrevivir para poder
comer
en 2017 nadie se atrevía a trabajar en
los campos que rodean la ciudad estar
solo acarreaba un alto riesgo de ser
atacado por el ejército o los bandidos
desde entonces otros también se han
aventurado a trabajar aquí
lo que cultivamos es muy importante en
estos momentos el país se enfrenta a una
crisis alimentaria
el día que vuelva la paz todo el mundo
tendrá que cultivar para que nadie pase
hambre en Sudán del sur
dos tercios de la población sufren
insuficiencia alimentaria y están en
peligro de morir por inacción Incluso en
el momento más crítico de la guerra
civil la situación no era tan grave las
tierras del sur de Sudán son
extremadamente fértiles pero la
inestabilidad impide que la gente se
establezca allí a largo plazo años de
cosechas fueron destruidas dejando a los
agricultores en la ruina
tenemos que pensar dónde instalarnos
luego tenemos que ver De cuánto capital
disponemos para montar un negocio Pero
hay que pensar en el futuro la
agricultura es un negocio caro muy caro
si uno no tiene dinero no puede
subsistir Sudán del sur también
atraviesa una grave crisis económica la
nación es una de las menos desarrolladas
del mundo más del 80% de la población
vive por debajo del umbral de pobreza
todos los días que olían a vender sus
productos Este es el mayor mercado de
Yuba Sofía cuánto me das por esto
por eso 200 Te parece bien
los precios cambian todos los días Ya
que la moneda está en constante
fluctuación aquí o el yang le resulta
difícil obtener ganancias tiene que
importar semillas fertilizantes y
pesticidas y los paga en dólares pero el
valor de la libra Sur su danesa ha caído
estrepitosamente desde el inicio de la
guerra civil en 2013 un dólar equiva Lía
a 3 libras actualmente equivale a más de
750 la mayoría de las cosas que uno
encuentra en el mercado les pertenecen a
extranjeros nosotros los ciudadanos no
podemos montar un negocio a largo plazo
la mayoría de los comerciantes aquí son
uganceses
no tenemos dinero poder abrir una tienda
y vender artículos al por mayor como lo
hacen ellos es muy caro
es imposible competir con estos
comerciantes extranjeros y es difícil
comprarles comida los salarios no han
aumentado al ritmo de la inflación
solo consume lo que produce le envía el
poco dinero que gana a su familia que
huyó a uganda
este Refugio Es lo mejor que puede
permitirse
estos son los bidones que utilizo para
mi campo
es una vida difícil pero al menos puede
trabajar sin riesgos
al menos aquí la seguridad es más o
menos buena no como en el campo desde
que estalló la guerra en 2017 no he
vuelto a mi pueblo
si la seguridad volviera a la normalidad
todo el mundo volvería a casa y
trabajaría Allí todo el mundo Sería
feliz
yang decenas de miles de personas han
llegado de todo el país para vivir en
Yuba
aunque no se mezclan los distintos
grupos étnicos ahora cohabitan
desde la independencia la ciudad ha
recibido más de 150.000 habitantes cada
vez hay más edificios
[Música]
cada vez hay más carreteras asfaltadas
los campos de batalla de antes se han
transformado
en 2016 este café y centro de arte aún
no existía nadie se atrevía a instalarse
en esta zona en el corazón de los
enfrentamientos
era un lugar peligroso entre 2003 y 2016
mucha gente murió por acá
pero hoy puede verse que la gente
Disfruta de la música se relaja bebé
significa que la zona se ha vuelto
pacífica
Morgan es un pintor y cantante muy
conocido en Yuba
junto con otros artistas organiza una
serie de eventos para crear una escena
local esta tarde viene un amigo a
ensayar con él antes de un concierto
[Música]
utilizo mi música para cambiar la
mentalidad de la forma de pensar de la
gente Entonces
les hago olvidar lo que pasó y les ayudo
a enfocarse en el futuro
mi objetivo es que la gente entienda que
todos estamos juntos en esto podemos
bailar al mismo ritmo cantar en
dialectos diferentes pero compartir el
mismo mensaje
[Aplausos]
[Música]
los pocos espacios culturales de Sudán
del sur se encuentran en Yuba
el centro yakuron fundado en 1976 es el
más antiguo de la capital todos los
jueves reúne a cantantes y humoristas
[Música]
Así es como los artistas se imaginan el
futuro de la ciudad
es el único lugar donde todos los Sur
sudaneses pueden reunirse todos los
grupos étnicos festejan utilizando una
sola lengua el árabe de yua y a veces un
poco de inglés Eso es todo yo lo llamo
el lugar de la unidad Aquí no hay
tribalismo no hay guerra estamos Unidos
como Sur sudaneses
olvidar la guerra los problemas de
dinero burlarse los unos de los otros
sin riesgo de que haya violencia
[Aplausos]
durante unas horas los espectadores
pueden olvidarse de su devastador pasado
un soplo de aire fresco muy necesario el
41% de los habitantes de Yuba sufren de
trastorno por estrés postraumático
el público se deja llevar por las
canciones de amor de Morgan
hospital tener lugares como este en
Sudán del sur no solo en Yuba sino
también en los demás estados
nuestra gente necesita distracciones que
los alejen de sus traumas
de hecho este show es una terapia
con nuestra historia
De dónde venimos entre 2013 y 2016 y
hacia dónde vamos la gente está muy
traumatizada y este es el lugar perfecto
para curarlos
hará falta tiempo para curar las heridas
de los yubaneses María kiollán y Morgan
desean pasar la página de la guerra
[Música]
la paz no depende solo de ellos pero
cada uno intenta dar lo mejor de Sí para
que Yuba sea por fin la capital de un
país Unido
[Música]
Gracias por acompañarnos en esta edición
de boleto de vuelta desde Sudán del sur
visitamos Yuba el único territorio del
país en el que se respeta el acuerdo de
paz de 2015 recuerde que puede Ingresar
a nuestra página web France 24.com para
ver esta emisión y las anteriores hasta
la próxima
[Música]